vielen dank für die vorstellung ich
halte diesen vortrag dass seine ziel
waren immer auf die heute nicht dabei
sein kann aber wir haben zusammen diesen
fotos konzipiert und auch dieses
forschungsprojekt oder genauer gesagt
petitions projekt und dass es diesem
vortrag geht es geht also um die
digitale konstellation forschung am
beispiel der klassischen deutschen
philosophie und wir nennen dieses
projekt as cannes tiana digitalis was
damit genau gemeint ist werden wir im
folgenden noch genauer zeigen ja die
ziele unseres vortrags unseres
forschungsprojekts bestehen darin die
der henrichs programm der konstellation
forschung das in den 80er und 90ern vor
allem den 90ern sehr aufwendig und auch
erfolgreich betrieben wurde auf digitale
weise zu realisieren im sinne einer
digitalen konstellation special wir
wollen diese digitale konstellation
forschung was darunter genau zu
verstehen das werden wir auch noch
zeigen wir wollen die auf die etats kann
diana die wir jetzt beschränkung von
1770 bis 1814
ungefährdet kritischen schrift von kant
bis zu seinem tod an wänden auf dieses
korpus und wir wollen dann untersuchen
was mögliche aspekt und dimension einer
etats kann diana digitales sind so
nennen wir unser petitions projekt und
wir wollen abschließend noch untersuchen
wie wir die stirn managers methoden
sinnvoll in eine von uns so gefasste
digitale konstellation forschung
integrieren können wie man das kann
paradigmatisch anhand der etats kann
tiana diesem zeitraum und dazu will ich
auch ein paar beispiele bringen wie man
zum beispiel mit text visualisierung
hier ganz interessant im sinne einer
konstellation forschung arbeiten kann es
muss man sich zunächst fragen was ist
eigentlich konstellation forschung
ziemlich hier wir beziehen uns hier auf
diesen band konstellation forschung
herausgegeben von martin mulsow of
muscle & stammen dabei von sehr vielen
experten experten zugenommen auf dieter
henrichs
programm hier ein zitat aus dem buch
beschreibung zitat konstellation
forschung ist der name einer forschungs
methode zur untersuchung von theorie
entwicklungen und kreativen impulsen die
aus dem zusammenwirken von verschiedenen
denken in einem gemeinsamen denkraum
entstehen noch ein weiteres zitat von
martin mulsow in seinem beitrag zu
diesem plan zitat eine philosophische
konstellation kann man definieren als
dichten zusammenhang wechselseitig
aufeinander einwirken der personen ideen
theorien probleme oder dokumente in der
weise dass nur die analyse dieses
zusammenhang ist nicht aber seine
isolierten bestandteil ein verstehen der
philosophischen leistung und entwicklung
der person ideen und theorien möglich
gemacht konstellationen sollten von
beginn an als vielschichtige komplexe
begriffen werden die sowohl personen und
ihre motivationslage als auch ideen
probleme und theorien sowie deren
niederschläge in dokumenten umfassen das
ist jetzt so der hintergrund der ich
möchte meinen analogen konstellation
forschung wird dem wir uns jetzt fragen
wie wir das ganze transformieren können
in eine digitale konstellation forschung
was die vorteile einer solchen
konstellation zu forschen zunächst aber
noch ein bisschen mehr auf die da
hinrichs analogie konstellation
forschung eingehend möchten wir sein
buch vorstellen mit dem titel
konstellationen probleme und debatten am
ursprung der idealistischen philosophie
für dieter henrich und auch für uns ist
ganz wichtig diese ursprünge aufzusuchen
wo sich die ganzen entwicklung
informiert haben in abgrenzung
verhältnissen die daher ich schreib und
diese 1991 erschienenen buch zitat kann
zwar noch mit der publikation seiner
hauptwerke beschäftigt und die
diskussion über kann zwar kaum in vollem
gang als 1789 dieser prozess begann er
kam grunde schon mit 296 zu ende mit dem
beginn der romantischen theorie mit der
etablierung des homburger kreises und
mit schellings frühen werk und kann
diesen vorgang metaphorisch als die
explosion einer supernova beschreibt es
gibt nichts vergleichbares in der
geschichte der philosophie allenfalls im
klassischen at man sieht diesen prozess
geschehen aber man könnte ihn nur
verstehen wenn es wie bei der erklärung
des entstehens einer supernova gelingt
mit genauen beschreibung und erklärung
in sein innerstes einzudringen während
die supernova aber das ende eines sterns
anzeigt war der eruptiven prozess der
1789 begann der aufgang einer denkt art
und der beginn einer woche also ein
interessanter metapher der supernova die
duh hendrich hier bemüht und er hat noch
ein wichtiges zitat dass wir hier
zitieren möchten sie tat es muss eine
denkweise herausgearbeitet und
wissenschaftlich respektabel gemacht
werden die dazu entstanden ist das dem
wirklichen leben eingebildete denken in
eine theorie vom einzubringen und zu
übersetzen und jetzt kann man sich
fragen kann man diese theorie form so
konzipieren dass sie eine digitale
vernetzte form ist oder auch eine
virtuelle form darauf werden wir noch
genauer eingehen also die frage kann man
diese kann man eine solche denkweise
entwickeln mit hilfe von digitaler
technik digitalen methoden gilt studium
energies die dieser dieser konstellation
von der die dringliche spricht besonders
adäquat ist vielleicht sogar noch
adäquat alles ist eine analoge
konstellation forschung sein kann wir
müssen natürlich auch möglich die
grenzen einer solchen digitalität und
konzentrations forschen reflektieren was
ist jetzt digitale konstellation
forschung zunächst ganz allgemein durch
über textuelle verknüpfungen die man
digital realisiert natürlich auch
analoge hypertext verweisung systeme in
lexika und weiter wir reden jetzt hier
immer von digitalen oder genauer
vielleicht sogar virtuelle hypertext
wählen verknüpfung slink entsteht ein
digitaler virtueller den traum der nicht
chronologisch sukzessive seien in
verschiedene richtungen gewissermaßen
horizontal befolgt werden könnte das ist
eine besonderheit dieses
digitalen hauses personen den theorie
probleme und dokumente aller art können
digital aufeinander bezogen werden das
geht natürlich auch im analogen raum
aber neben nicht auf dieselbe art und
weise und darauf gehen mir heute gleich
noch ein bisschen mehr ein und es ist
möglich durch den einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz
konstellation muster zu finden
aufzuspüren zu erkennen also hier haben
wir noch ganz viele möglichkeiten der
integration andere techniken in einem
komplexen prozess der digitalen
konstellation forschen und nicht zuletzt
die offenheit und anbindung dieser
digitalen konstellation dieser über
texte realisiert mit konzentration an
weitere konstellation die es ja auch
noch gibt so entsteht dann am ende eine
riesen kontext dem nicht nur auf die
klassische deutsche philosophie
beschränkt ist ja was kann jetzt
digitale konstellation forschung leisten
ganz konkret zum beispiel bislang nur in
frakturschrift verstreut digital
zumindest vorliegende text sie ließ dann
machen und einem größeren interessierten
publikum zugänglich zu machen begriffs
und co personenkonstellation
visualisieren und hypertext will
bedeutsam verbinden also nicht nur
irgendwie
quantitativ verbinden sondern wirklich
mit semantischer bedeutung aufladen das
muss man natürlich genauer noch zeigen
dann editorische und inhaltliche
kommentare direkt mit den quellen
hypertext will verbinden hier fließt
alles in diesem kontext ein die digitale
konstellation ist also eine reibungslose
körper textuelle konstellation die einen
andere konstellation reibungsfrei und
virtuell anschlussfähig betonte den
aspekt der reibungs freiheit weil der
mir nichts äußerliches zu sein scheint
sondern als essentielles für die
digitale konstellation forschung eine
digitale konstellation konzentrations
forschung wird damit selbst zu einem
virtuellen prozesse und wie ich schon
sagte kann auch die künstliche
intelligenz und die konzentrations
forschung integriert werden ja jetzt
möchte ich die etats kann tiana die
unserer forschungs edition gegenstand
ist als info sphäre charakterisieren da
knüpfen wir anderen luciano floridis
buch die vierte revolution wie die infos
wäre unser leben verändert und wie ich
schon sagte können wir eine über texte
nicht vernetzte digitale edition im
sinne von sozialer floridis begriff der
info sphäre zu stehen was meint jetzt
florida unter diesem begriff der info
sphäre er sagt zitat weit gefasst ist
die info sphäre ein begriff der sie auch
synonym mit wirklichkeit verwenden lässt
wenn wir letztere information l
auffassen diesem fall ließe sich sagen
dass wirklich ist ist information l und
das informationelle ist ist wirklich
eine abwandlung eines hübschen zitat in
ebendieser entsprechung liegt die wurzel
einige der tiefgreifendsten wandlungen
und schwierigsten probleme die im
zusammenhang mit der technologie
demnächst auf uns zukommen werden ganz
entscheiden ich hatte schon von gesagt
ist hier los llanos begriff einen
reibungsfreien infos fähre in der info
sphäre in der alles informationelle
vorliegt und vernetzt ist finden diese
vernetzung reibungsfrei stadt anders als
im analogen raum wo wir räumliche
zeitliche
distanzen überwinden müssen und wir
wirklich auch physikalisch einer
gewissen reibung unterliegen die diesen
prozess der vernetzung von langsam
vielleicht auch stört oder verändert das
heißt die reibungslose ich kite in der
info sphäre die auch eine digitale über
textuelle edition betreffen kann dies
nichts aktuelles und ihr äußerliches
sondern sie ist struktur bilden sie ist
wirklich für diese edition
charakteristisch und daran wollen wir
weiter anknüpfen mit blick auf die frage
nach einer digitalen konstellation
zwischen das möchte ich aber erst was
allgemein zur bedeutung der etats kann
diana haben die etats kann diana ist
insbesondere deswegen von philosophen
städte torische relevanz da sie eine
vielzahl an heterogen texten fasst die
sich allesamt als reaktion auf ganz
philosophie verstehen lassen seien es
kritische kleinere rezension polemische
reaktion produktive rezeption oder gar
eigenständige weiterentwicklung wie man
es zum beispiel bei fichte oder hegel
sieht zwar liegen zu den bekannten
philosophen dieser zeit wie jacobi
reinholz schiller fichte schelling jäger
hervorragend der edition vor im rahmen
von arcania ausgaben doch fehlt bislang
immer noch eine edition die die
philosophische und historische bedeutung
der weniger bekannten sogenannten
kleineren denker des trifft muss
wirklich zu dokumentiert und auch in ein
verhältnis zu den fans durch den
größeren denken die schon kokettiert
vorliegen ersetzt james clark gable
gottlieb sprechen einen neuen sammelband
von einem zitat revisionen scholarship
bezüglich der nach kantischen
philosophie und einem monster of the
development of germany die listen des
challengers der standort rebellion
meredith also die das nigerianische
narrativ dass es eben diesen drei
schritt gibt wir immer eine klare
abfolge von stationen fichte schelling
igel
dieses neuere forschungsinteresse
fokussiert jetzt weniger auf die
railroad diesen königsweg sondern kann
über fichte zu schädigen gegen sondern
auch kein zitat network of base also
neben wege die nicht ganz auf diese
großen hauptstraße liegen die aber
dennoch wichtig sind ohne die wir auch
diese hauptstraße nicht gut erkunden
können also das ist ganz wichtig die
aktuelle forschung konzentriert sich auf
diese unbekannteren denker und die
liegen eben noch gar nicht wirklich text
will sicher vor da ist noch viel arbeit
zu leisten
jetzt gibt es eine sammlung vieler
dieser texte der etats kann diana die
hat denselben titel etwas kann diana im
puzzle erschienen von 1968 abkühlt ihre
zivilisation
hier liegen bisher unter diesem titel 3
75 bände in einer statischen
faksimiledruck zumeist faktur vor die
eben in diesem verlag im zeitraffer 168
bis 1981 veröffentlicht wurden und ein
noch viel weiteren zeitung nämlich
zwischen 17 5 und 17 und 18 85 umfassen
alle diese bände können digital urheber
frei heruntergeladen werden kostenlos
über wiki source hier ist einmal die
adresse
viele dieser texte sind jedoch bislang
nicht editorisch erschlossen die
allermeisten und sie liegen nicht einmal
in digitalisierter lateinischer schrift
vor seien eben nur in frakturschrift und
das ist ein großes problem natürlich
auch von über textuelle verknüpfen und
schon ganz wenn man künstliche
intelligenz auf dieses korpus ansetzen
möchte hier ist noch mal ein bild von
dieser etwas kann diana optik ist so aus
das sieht man also hier die ersten 17
bände es gibt wie gesagt 375 man kann
sich die alle unterlagen sid ich habe ja
auch schon einige runtergeladen die
liegende guten qualität vor aber eben
nicht ocr behandelt das heißt wir können
damit erstmal gar nichts inhaltliches
anfang aber es eine erste basis zu
wenden hier möchte ich noch ein paar
beispiele bringen aus seinem besitz der
erste band plan einer systematischen
metaphysik von der kopf friedrich abel
professoren der hohen karlsschule in
stuttgart von 1787 und jedes team an
seite wie das aussieht klar fraktur und
nicht ocr behandelt da kann man erstmal
nicht viel mit anfang immerhin muss man
nicht in die archive gehen und dieses
dokument noch digitalisiert da ist schon
also eine vorarbeit geleistet vor ja was
umfasst jetzt dieses projekt etwas
kannte einer digital ist zunächst die
sammlung der digitalisate der digitalen
texte aus diesem zeitraum 1770 bis 18.4
dass unsere beschränkung grundlage für
die konstituierung des textkorpus ist
die übergriffe von artikeln die bis zum
jahr 1804 fast 3000 mehr ihre einträge
verzeichnet werden die sich auf
irgendeine weise mit ganz philosophie
befasst haben dann geht es darum
verschiedene systematische teil diskurse
zu identifizieren unter anderem freiheit
determinismus moral begründung
moralischer motivation
religionsphilosophie naturphilosophie
erkenntnis philosophie skeptizismus
ästhetik theorie der gefühle emotionen
politikern naturrecht das ist noch lange
nicht alles das in der partei dieses
kurse die sich hier sehr wohl
identifizieren natürlich auch immer im
kontext
relation ihren lassen und diese teil
diskurse data skandia einer
demonstrieren ihre interdisziplinäre
relevanz und erlauben auch eine
anbindungen andere forschungsprojekte im
kontext der klassischen deutschen
philosophie ja überhaupt der geschichte
der philosophie das heißt man kann ihr
konstellation noch viel größer und
weiter fassen wenn man alle texte gut
ediert und per ocr verfahren vorliegend
hat was sind jetzt die methoden einer
möglichen etats kann diana digitales ich
hatte es schon erwähnt die texte in
frakturschrift müssen transkribiert
werden die lateinische schrift mittels
ocr verfahren und natürlich auch
mittelständische kultur sicherlich kann
mir auch keine prozesse noch mit besser
einfließen lassen dann müssen diese
digitalisierten texte von uns ins xml
format gebracht und ausgezeichnet werden
nach ti standard durch die verwendung
dieses internationalen edition standards
ist dann auch die anschlussfähigkeit
anderen und künftige digitale edition
gewährleistet wir wollen dann auch diese
texte eine strukturierte text datenbank
integrieren und im rahmen einer online
edition open access veröffentlicht hier
ist ihnen ganz wichtig dass diese texte
untereinander hypertext will verlinkt
werden und deswegen weil sie aufeinander
selbst bezug nehmen und so versuchen wir
einen dichten diskussions zusammenhang
zu etablieren in dem sich die
vorstellung der forscher wirklich
einklinken kann und dann in alle
möglichen richtungen chronologisch
vorwärts rückwärts begrifflich
orientieren kann also ein denkraum ein
digitaler virtueller denkt der wirklich
nachvollzogen werden kann soll dadurch
entstehen ja also dann geht es noch
darum
historisch philosophischen editorischen
kommentar zu verfassen und auch diesen
kommentar wieder um hypertext will mit
diesen texten oder auch begriffen zu
verlinken wir wollen uns dabei
beschränken nur auf die direkte kant
rezeption und die rezeption andere
bedeutender philosophischen für die
klassische tonstudio sowie in osaka kobe
und auch auf die politischen ereignisse
auf die auch darin bezogen haben wird
man kann diesen ethischen bereich
natürlich noch viel größer fassen aber
das ist uns momentan nicht möglich dann
wollen wir auch ein digitales begriffs
register glossar erstellen um dann auch
unter rückgriff auf enorm daten eine
direkte verlinkung herzustellen ja hier
schon gesagt eben die sind diese
technischen mittel die wir anwenden im
arm auch vom diebstahl managers
verfahren aber noch sehr rudimentäre
neben der technischen art
die am ende ist noch zu betont dass man
auch visualisierung von begriffs
korrelationen topologien person und werk
konstellation und intersexuelle bezüge
herstellen kann so sieht das ganze dann
aus xml verfahren aber jetzt ein
beispiel um hallo welt aus wikipedia
also da muss man schon noch mal einiges
als hintergrund logik gewissermaßen
entwickeln bevor man das ganze dann so
schön reibungslos vernetzen kann aber so
diese form würde das am ende dann
gebracht werden jetzt möchte ich noch
ein bisschen auf die methoden der
dienststelle managers eingehen die sich
hier für diese etwas kann johanna
digitales anbieten ein besonders gutes
sehr intuitiv ein gängiges tool ist
waren stuhls
hier kann man einfach das corpus direkt
hier ein hinein kopieren oder auch bei
hochladen einladen drag and drop geht
glaube ich auch und im nächsten schritt
sieht man dann das hier ich habe zwar
ein kapitel aus kants kritik der reinen
vernunft unbearbeitet eingeladen und
sieht hier allerdings eine cs wollte die
krebs wolke wo sie auch noch wo man noch
begriffe sieht die vielleicht jetzt
nicht wirklich wichtig sind die
erfordert also ich habe es jetzt nicht
sortiert oder gar ausgesiebt manche
begriffe das kann man natürlich dann
auch machen im nach
bearbeitungsverfahren
es gibt schon automatisch
voreingestellte listen die füllwörter
rausfiltern die nicht wichtig sind die
kann man modifizieren hier sieht man zum
beispiel testen ist oder after a priori
oder auch die zahl 2 das ist jetzt nicht
entscheidend ja hier sieht man jetzt
schon eben in diesem zweiten feld dass
hier begriffe in eine bestimmte
konstellation gebracht werden hier sieht
man schon eine schwache unbearbeitete
konstellation einer begriffs
konstellation kann man natürlich noch
viel besser fildern auch fokussieren
hier sieht man weitere
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten von von
bestimmten wörtern die hier einen trend
anzeigen in der entwicklung des textes
hin zur häufigkeit als gibt unendlich
viele möglichkeiten dass ich hier durch
text visualisierung ausgehen zu lassen
und eben auch im sinne einer
konstellation verstehen zu lassen ja wir
knüpfen jetzt hier an einen dg netzwerk
was ich geleitet hatte zum thema
freiheit murat politik praktische
philosophie im ausgang von kants 17 85
bis 1800 und wir haben jetzt mal ein
paar digital humanities methoden mit
hilfe von neuen tools darauf angewendet
jedem fall aus diesen praktischen
diskurs verhält moral politik mit hilfe
der text visualisierung hier haben wir
jetzt als corpus immanuel kant
grundlegend zur metaphysik der sitten
hier haben wir es mal fokussiert auf
allein praktische begriffe also will
1100 handlung und wir sehen jetzt hier
gewisse entwicklungen in dieser nach
kantischen konstellation die eine
verschiebung bedeuten also diele und
vernunft sind hier sehr engen verbunden
man sieht es dadurch dass die
verbindungslinien dicker sind das heißt
es hier gibt es eine engere
korrelationen die dünneren linien sind
hier weniger ausgeprägt also vernunft
und wille stehen jedoch in recht engen
verhältnis und jetzt kann man schauen
wie sich das in der nach kannte schritte
partie endete 2 johann august hat ulrich
und seine leute theologie
hier sieht man jetzt hier spielt die
notwendigkeit auch eine große rolle
zugleich spricht er noch von graden der
freiheit das ist ganz wichtig dass würde
kann so bestimmt nichts sagen also sieht
man hier kommt der freiheitsbegriff in
bewegung und noch eine interessante
statistik ihr diese begriffswolke auch
von ulrich widmann notwendigkeit ist
noch vor freiheit also notwendigkeit ist
ganz ganz wichtig vernunft und
notwendigkeit der kommunismus ist
wichtig hier sieht man gewisse
prioritäten und zogen auf weiteren text
dass mehrere sponsoren ein richtig
wirklich freiheit des willens auch ein
recht unbekannter text vielleicht noch
einer der bekannteren texte hier sieht
man jetzt eine verschiebung hier wird
jetzt der wille nicht mehr so sehr wie
der grundlegung zu metallisierten mit
der vernunft in einer beziehung gebracht
mit gründen und die gründe sind jetzt
nicht mehr die praktische vernunft sind
das kann einem möglichen gründe seien
und sogar die gründe können gefühle sein
das würde kann natürlich nie sagen dass
das möglich ist dass gefühle gründe
unseres autonome oder freien willens
sind es wäre ihr dann hätte rungen je
gefühle pathologische also wir sehen
hier gibt es verschiedene veränderungen
auch willens erscheinungen diese rede
davon spricht kann auch nicht sehr
interessant was ich hier alles gibt das
heißt wir können jetzt abschließend noch
ein paar perspektiven der konstellation
vorschein einer digitalen konstellation
forschen vorschlagen also begriffs netze
machen begrifflich und thematische
schwerpunkte in einem wird sichtbar die
texte können mit anderen text bezüglich
ihrer begrifflichen und thematischen
schwerpunkte verglichen werden die texte
können auch synchron verglichen werden
herzlich verschiedenen autoren und die
thematischen entwicklung können auch die
agro und sowohl im werk eines autors in
einem korpus zum beispiel von kann von
der grundlegung sie mit der physiker
sich bis zum späten metaphysik der
sitten
nachverfolgt und dargestellt werden als
timeline zum beispiel so können auch
bestimmte konjunkturen bestimmter
debatten wie etwa zur freiheit die marke
gant ifi ziert werden dem gefühls
begriff könnte man hier nennen den
begriff des
und dann mit hilfe von texturen
metadaten tägigen von personennamen
werken zitaten können eben auch
systematisch in der textstelle bezüge
aufgedeckt werden also die frage stellte
zum beispiel welchen texten welche
autoren findet sich ein bezug auf ganz
freiheits konzeption an welchen stellen
seines werks bezieht sich ein auto auf
kant und warum vielleicht auf welche
andere text sind motoren bezieht sich
ein auto riesen unterschied wie werden
diese fragen lassen sich eben
unmittelbar reibungslos ausgeben
visualisieren was bei einer analogen
funktionswäsche neben überhaupt nicht
möglich ist das heißt bezüge dieser art
konstituieren konstellation in
definierten sinn die digitale
konstellation zwischen ist umfassend es
geht um einen textkorpus anstatt
einzelne können wirklich alles
berücksichtigen sie ist auch global fast
nicht nur einzelne texte lokal sie ist
systematisch sie wertet das textkorpus
als ganzes aus und sie ist gezielt das
heißt sie beantwortet spezifische
fragestunde nachdem wir suchen können
wir können also auch eine solche
konstellation wie 1 1 internet verbinden
und dann suchanfragen stellen und sie
ist natürlich auch explora tief weil sie
zum beispiel mit hilfe des einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz auch neue
konstellation auch finden kann die wir
so die wir etwas vielleicht auch mit
scheuklappen sind gar nicht finden
würden ja hat es wäre eine
kurzvorstellung unseres edition des
projekts vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit